Mike where do you where D weigh in on
Christian McCaffrey Leonard fournette
sitting out these bowl games man I'm
split on this band you know I really am
because I gotten older I understand the
side of business and and and and
everything and making a decision that's
best for you in the future but I'm kind
of old gut to you know what I mean I got
a commitment to the guise of well 45
guys that are on the football team that
are out here each week and that's kind
of what make us do what we do is to
commit me that we make one to another so
I'm definitely split but if you could
have come out after your junior year
right I didn't come out up to my Jewish
years but I graduated out to my junior
year and I left squirrelly and I
finished the season you can of course I
was playing for national championship
that would work if you were playing in
the Sun Bowl would ya and you were
guaranteed to be a first-round draft
pick now I know it's different now than
it was back then because nobody was
doing it and there's so many more bowl
games now but you know you wanted to
take care of your family and Lord knows
your family could use the help back then
if you knew that you could do that and
make sure that you wouldn't get hurt
would you you know play in a bowl game
that didn't mean anything as opposed to
the national title game yeah I i I'm
with you I understand that side of it I
understand that side of it but the bass
the bass line of what we do as a
football team is football players is a
commitment to one another and that
commitment has been broken there and I'm
sorry that disturbs me I understand what
they're doing but the baseline of what
we're doing out here together is the
commitment to one another and that's the
thing that's been woven three
championship team I've had and I've been
unfortunate to play on is a commitment
one man to another I would get my job
done and I would do my job that that
that that's all I know and thatthat's
Esther fee no matter what you're going
to tell me how great of a business
decision and they can have 16 brothers
and sisters waiting just like I had
waited with their hands out saying hey
baby you're too stock that more toward
all of that I understand but a baseline
is the commitment and that still
disturbs me well we don't have problem
with coaches leaving yeah thnkx they
quit on the entire team what it would if
what is that and and that's why
sometimes in a huddle when you get to
the guys you either say to the guys hey
this is about us yeah I don't care about
the coaches I don't care about did year
I don't care about anything this is
about us on this football field right
now I've said that a lot of times to my
teammates because that's what it's about
it's about us they are not out here
running routes they're not I here
throwing the ball and not on a blocking
and not only running the ball it's about
us and that's just what it is he's
Michael Irvin the hall of famer thursday
night football continues this week giant
eagles on NBC the NFL network and this
sunday the ravens play the steelers at
four thirty eastern on the NFL network
you remember your first paycheck with
the Cowboys oh yeah what'd you do with
it oh oh you don't want to hear Danny
now i do like oh ok listen i got my
first i got my first was signing bonus i
got my first sight among i left a check
on the counter at the house forever my
people were calling me every day may you
gotta send in the check Michaelson in
the gym I would lose an interest on such
as they're losing interest everybody
walks at this house and see their check
I'm getting a whole lot of interest I
don't know what you're talking about I
left that they go on the counter they
were everything that walked in that
house walked it and yeah when they saw
that things got real easy it was nice so
the brothers and sisters all you put the
check on the counter so your brothers
and sisters could see that kind of money
when my brother this was coming in my
house at that time re Bob oh no so
overall it was other other other people
covered in at a time and they had to see
it ended yeah yeah it was I was young
then I was young I wish I would have
known you back then how would I how
would I have done with you if I was if I
was your your partner it old fellow man
this hell I must have been the brokers
do it at the world and it gave me a
check like that are you joking you know
I was faking it was with that many
zeros behind it there was no way i was
running that right to the bank without
showing it off first you know so i
showed it off for a while I'd uh brought
this up before you came on about the
celebration with Ezekiel Elliott in the
Salvation Army bucket Odell Beckham jr.
said he would have been fined if he did
the same thing and I do agree with him
do you think that it would have been
different with ODB as opposed to Ezekiel
know the back that was and that was a
grout like what is it you did because it
is such a time and where in the holiday
season and everybody's talking about
passing out gifts and all these things
that he brings attention to some people
that are less fortunate then I said
that's that's a cool thing but I'm with
over the l2 I believe he would have been
fine too it's just what it is when it
comes to odile you know he smiles on the
sideline and that's all we're talking
about no matter how in a bad ball z like
made through during that game so so he
had i believe he has a point here right
i believe he has a point if i said you
can have the future of ODB Julio Jones
or Antonio Brown they're all heaven what
did we were left there all have it right
here if we got a draft right now Mike
you gotta give me something man you got
the first pick you got the first pic I
got the second pick out of those guys
which one I'm to dropped in first yeah I
probably Julio because of his size and
he is as fast as any of them with that
sighs you know but each one of them have
such great skill sets man is a
phenomenal receivers man odelle odelle
but just a beast I mean an Antonio Brown
is also so I the one you can't lose but
just give it on a draft I'm probably
going to go for size I still have the
speed and Julio Jones do you think the
gloves are unfair an unfair advantage of
performance enhancer oh boy I there's no
doubt that the glove help but we don't
because of the gloves we don't need to
unless timate what we're seeing you know
with these guys is that stuff though del
does and warm up catching the ball with
one hand and we never tried that we
never even tried let alone thought about
doing it you know I hour
one here in catches were not snatching
them out of the air they were knocking
them back down to you you put up the one
hand and knock the ball back to you you
never put the one hand up and snatch the
ball right there between heaven and
earth you never did that these kids are
doing it now and think about this man
when you grew up you know three four
five six seven years old you get to play
organized ball when I was growing up at
five six seven years ago you didn't play
organized ball and when you wish to the
park to play a basketball court they
said let's get your butt down you ain't
ready to play yes you can even play with
these guys so you know you're getting
early early early training just took to
develop all of those skills says those
one hand catches and all of that so I
understand what people talk about when
they talk about the glove but let's not
take credit away from the gift that
these kids have and that in the talent
that they've worked on to do the things
that we're seeing over there back when
those guys do oh I'm just saying that we
outlawed stickam but if you've ever well
you have you put on these gloves they
can make you a little better wide
receiver because there's stick them on
these gloves but they they're not going
to allow you to have stickam the way
Lester Hayes at it but these gloves have
that tacky feeling on them yeah they do
they do it and they didn't allow you
wear stickam and Jay writes I didn't
have more stickam and all of that stuff
and we could put all that out there but
but but how did Jerry use the stick in
Michael cuz I don't know it was some
Jerry throughout I did on my timeline
all my social media stuff I don't want
to indict year right and their people
say I'm just trying to knock off the
goat he is the goat that's just I get
that stuff all the time to people asking
about sticking with me Jerry cheater
million years ago I was like stopping
people stop it that stuff was not police
like it is right now better at a younger
age Emmett or Ezekiel Elliott my great
question that's a great question i mean
Ezekiel has that that fifth gear and
speed and I don't think that Emma did
not have but a man had balanced beyond
anybody man and both of them was greater
young I don't know if you can determine
better or not but I'll tell you this
I'll see it this way the offensive line
Emmitt head was never considered great
prior to
Emmitt Smith it was just a bunch of boys
playing offensive line and then image
came and they became one of the greatest
offensive lines in the history of the
game now the offensive line big head
they were great before he got there what
do you think Jerry that's a great
explanation my core but where did that
come from okay go ahead a women hold on
guy round of applause for my collage
right over here right on point you
recognize that and just nation it up and
I think okay there you are there they're
basically my offensive line Michael yeah
but tell him it's okay to clap with
somebody else's company with her foot
pain clap for you only there I i forget
what I was going to ask you now oh
that's right I remember do you have a
problem with Jerry Jones admitting that
he sort of manipulate the media with
this tony romo situation that he's kind
of poking fun prod pneus trying to get a
reaction out of us no I don't have a
problem with it in indicate i have a
problem with he is to be 0 if it is you
know third friday anybody with Hibbert
our organization can have a real problem
since he's the Bo S&S but but whatever
it is what he does do is a businessman
he knows it's about supply and demand
and if you have a demand for his supply
you think he wants you to supply then it
makes his supply worth more no do you
think he wants Tony Romo it makes him
worth more if you think he's going to
get rid of them you sit back and wait so
it's all business you started this whole
conversation out saying I understand
guys doing business but now when it
comes to the billionaire to be osns all
of a sudden you don't understand it then
don't put yourself in your own trap yeah
but I don't think this is business I
think Jerry's his own worst enemy if
we're going to look at the BOS NS uh you
know it's not like he was a great boss
and figuring out dak Prescott was going
to be his quarterback they did
everything they could to try to get
somebody else they stumbled into that
and a better stop like- top that is the
process that every team goes through
when it comes down to evaluating players
so
now to try to take credit away from them
getting debt Prescott saying they
stumbled up on that Prescott when the
draft is the process everybody Mike one
plank my appraiser they wanted they were
interested in carson wench they tried to
trade up desperately for packet Paxton
Lynch they thought about Johnny Manziel
a couple of years ago talk to the people
over at Mississippi he would they were
the only ones that really had interest
in that princess or so they were saying
we see something in him we're the only
ones that see something in him so we see
why side we tell one side of the story
and we don't deliver on the other side
and it makes it seems like it's
something other than what it is the
process by which they went to get tech
Prescott every 31 other teams were by
the same product red process to get over
the plate a guy they had a player on the
board they want it and then they got the
clear that they got now when he turns
out great do we keep saying how well you
really didn't even want this guy no they
went through the price they hide other
forts around Mike and same one in him
they wouldn't take off later for the fix
what do we say it so we got a pic right
away from New England forget it operate
in 26 no they accidentally fell into Tom
Brady absolutely I don't think anymore
man Otis Willie pictum he was here they
picked the sixth round a value not they
picked them at the value that was given
to the market not just the value they
have to him we were doing business then
remember we started this we business and
so even if they loved yet Prescott [ __ ]
they take them in the first round when
he'll be there in the fourth you see
what I'm saying come on then you run the
risk of somebody else taking him and
then that brilliant business decision
and so was it a smoke screen that you
were all in on Paxton Lynch and until
the Broncos swooped in and got him you
were taking him so no no no I'm not so
they would have taken Paxton Lynch Mike
and they would have missed out on the
best quarterback in the draft and Omega
nice and an if they got seven draft
picks they are only evaluate the seven
guys that they really want don't worry
about anybody else don't worry about
just the seven guys that you really
wanted which makes no sense then it
makes no sense you have to evaluate the
players you have interesting and then
get them according to how you can get
them best on the draft and that's the
process that the tour bus I don't know
why we're hot goin hot annoyed I don't
we'll just disagree on it I think the
cowboys lucked into dak Prescott and
they would have taken packs they would
have taken Paxton Lynch they loved his
offensive line they loved into Ezekiel
Elliott no no no they didn't look into
Ezekiel Elliott I said that was the
right pic of the time loved it I loved
it but they lucked into dak Prescott
Mike and you know and there's no reason
for you to acknowledge it publicly
because then Jarriel call you and yell
at you and I don't want that to counter
I just add it Michael I understand I
understand it Mike I understand I've got
it don't worry hey you know what like
the b.o.s.s doesn't affect me at all but
even I thank you stop me from saying
what I'm saying but I have a duty to
educate the crotchet craniums and
fertilizer brain and that's what i'm
doing right Mike Mike Mike I am ronnie
Lott you just came over the middle and
it's not pretty oh come on i gave you
good stuff you do take the loss like a
boss it's a loss like a boss and you
know what I take out the Oni else when
it comes to Jerry it's just being us
there just Ana Mike I keep it real by
keeping it real ah they got the order if
it doesn't you to be a dis are you a
true but you all right with three thank
you Mike whatever it's just business
[Applause]
alright guys that's Michael over the
playmaker the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]